Bella a tutti ragazzi e walcome Back to
wrestling
mi hanno preso
ha inizio adesso
all'alba tu ti unirai al nostro culto
accordi
dalla mia benedizione Ma non sono io
questo
non so è un tipo un incubo
Yes
perché all'alba ha detto Ricordiamoci
che tutto sto popò di roba la stiamo
facendo ragazzi in una notte Cioè
Resident Evil 4 il tempo di gioco in
realtà è una notte c'è il passa tutta la
notte che i miei episodi riescono ogni
giorno ma lui se l'è fatto tutta la
notte poi andare in discoteca prima di
questi tempi molto bene
Ah vedi che mi ricordavo che potevi
andare in giro con la barchetta quindi
all'alba mi trasformo All'alba vincerò
Speriamo
è affondata cazzo
No no sei stato in silenzio radio per
tre ore scusami c'era solo un mostro di
Dio Non succederà più
Sto ancora cercando una specie di chiave
ricevuta almeno stai Bene Chiudo
Ma che palle poi sei affondata la barca
Ma [__] Vabbè però la chiave della
chiesa Beh questo anche prima lo devo
fare non è che lo devo fare adesso
Allora ragazzi aveva detto che era
dall'altra parte del Lago siamo
dall'altra parte del Lago per ora ma non
ci gioco cazzo minchia è diventato
buissimo
E chi non salta non ci crede ma chi è
aprisa Ma io che cazzo ne so scusi basta
Ma chi è Oh merda stanno facendo un
esorcismo Oh
Ah ok Eccolo lo zio
Mannaggia un cazzo questo è
difficilissimo da buttare giù ragazzi
anzi t-shotta non vorrei dire una
cazzata ma tisciotta io con la mia Mira
di merda ogni cazzo di volta
Cioè ho buttato 8 proiettili per fare
sta roba questi qua da far fuori sono un
casino e inoltre ti shottano
da adesso in avanti se faccio saltare le
teste potrebbe succedere questa cosa
come Sta per succedere adesso perfetto
Ecco
Vabbè mi sembra un po' un'esagerazione
Vabbè aumentiamoci la vita va che prima
non avevo trovato l'erba Ah l'ho già
usata sono morto bene dai fa sempre
piacere
ok Forse posso seccarlo
è morto è morto Bene Ottimo
fantastico ragazzi No veramente
Ma che cazzo Ma che cazzo lo dico io lì
ogni tanto mi devo far fuori io questo
stiamo facendo adesso sono diventati
prima non era così adesso il virus
dentro di loro è mutato gli esce questo
Tentacolo di merda dalla testa una cosa
fantastica ragazzi guarda Non vedevo
l'ora
mi fate incazzare Comunque non ho
erbette quindi non posso qua guarda
quante granate che c'ho io appena vedo
un boss gli faccio saltare il coccige Ma
tutto questo il Mercante Dov'è razza
tipo che devo vendere le vipere Quella
roba mi serve io le vipere sto tenendo
Perché l'unica questa che sono riuscito
a completare finora
Ok Mi sa che qua c'è la chiave ragazzi è
questa no Sì appunto prendilo
Questa è la chiave Eh sì e prendi la
testa ah devo mettere qualcosa qua Oh
merda a due ne devo mettere devo mettere
due cose per sbloccare la chiave Vabbè
ma chi è che fa chi è che li fa sti
meccanismi Chi è c'è qualcuno che si
sveglia di notte dicevo facciamo sta
cosa qua oh oh
ho capito
mappa giornata Ah vedi vedi che non sono
stupido Ti fa andare in giro per il lago
Esamina Due luoghi Allora vedi che
poteva andare in giro brillare non sono
stupido
io e lo spirito di osservazione ragazzi
siamo due cose completamente opposte ok
ok
chiave degli alta Uh Questa è la chiave
degli altarini quelli che trovi in giro
bene me la posso sbloccare cose meno
male uovo di cane cerco qualcuno di
percorrere un nuovo regalino dorato dove
minchia lo Triggiano non trovo le cose
normali figuriamoci le cose dorate cioè
Vabbè un'altra barca qua Cioè Meno male
l'andamento scassare quella di prima per
questa cosa qua Però vabbè Yes non sono
pazza puoi ancora usare questo eh
va bene Ah addirittura puoi tornare al
mercante che è qui cioè voi potete
andare veramente ovunque ragazzi e
addirittura mi fa attraccare anche di
qua andiamo prima Dal mercante va
attenzione
Pezzetta molto bene
Come far tornare Dal mercante in tutto
questo vediamo perché almeno gli
consegno le vipere che non mi servono
più Allora mi scusi straniero come nuovi
cioè il lanciarazzi
ce l'ha ce l'ha bellissimo la gente ha
concluso la potenza devastante
estensione valigetta Allora innanzitutto
prima cosa one two three
proprio così cazzo m'ha dato ok
quattro Spinelli m'ha dato Imi di socio
da questa cosa ragazzi la valigetta nera
Aumenta le probabilità di trovare
risorse Non male ma per adesso io
comprerei la maschera
Aspetta che ti incastono le gemme
Vediamo quanto la vendo One
two
and free Madonna quanto l'hanno fatto
bene Ragazzi comunque incredibile Vai
Vendi tutto orologio fermaglio lacrime
maschera vendita qualsiasi E va bene
Madonna quanti poroso potenziare le cose
porca [__] sì eccolo Allora
innanzitutto aumentiamo l'arma al
massimo e anche la doppietta ci siamo
allora ragazzi teoricamente qua che devo
andare eh perché qua mi dice che devo
prendere uno dei due oggetti Mi ci devo
arrivare fin là facciamoci il giro e
amen
Stai zitto
ma che cazzo fate voi tutto il giorno
scusa cioè andate in giro nelle grotte
che mira terrifica Ah questi qua li
salta la testa attenzione che sono come
ragazzi devo fare attenzione adesso
perché gli salta la testa la gente non
ho ben capito non mi ricordo se li
faccio fuori normalmente senza fare
saltare la testa se si trasformano o
meno cioè se io gli sparo normale donna
senza polisate la testa Oddio scusa Sono
scivolato
facciamolo saltare in mezzo agli altri
Porca [__]
Ok ok Attenzione attenzione benissimo
perché c'è quello che lancia le bombe
sono contento dov'è È là
perfetto
bene raga
non è andata male come no dai Vi prego
Madonna Quanti sono minchia schifosi
incredibile Oh
stai fermo Porca [__] che è già
difficile sto gioco Freddy Kruger
comunque attenzione
Oh non è vero non è vero mai non è vero
mai
c'era il coso il simbolo del calcio non
me l'ha fatto tirare non ti prego anche
tu No ragazzi dai
sta roba raga è terrificante con questo
morendo in tutto ciò Minchia che male
non ho Cure Ah sì una
c'ho solo quella ragazzi devo stare
attento Non ho Cure Porca [__]
vabbè Minchia che cazzo Sei un cecchino
quanti ne hai di sti cosi
Vai Vai veloce veloce bravissimo
attenti E io ci ho provato ad avvertirti
Madonna raga quanti cazzo siete
via via via via via via via via via via
via via via via sali Sali Sali Sali Sali
ok
Nice non so bene se quelli trasformati
riescono a seguirti anche sopra le scale
Che cazzo è Oh c'è una roba da
schiacciare non ho visto
ok
Non ho capito Che cazzo è successo oh
ragazzi effettivamente adesso sto
finendo i proiettile perché questi qua e
di così sta roba qua la devo premerli
con un certo ordine Pure minchia già è
un casino
Vabbè io sono qua Eccoli
1 2 Allora uno è questo ci faccio la
foto col telefono almeno lo sblocco
tutto
uno
due tre uno
due penso sia questo sotto
e tre l'ultimo tipo questo
yeah ragazzi Madonna Tutto qua Grazie
grazie mille Mi dai un sacco di a testa
della prostata a della prostata Ah mi sa
che era quello che
Ah mi sa che era proprio quello che
dovevo fare per andare avanti Ah qui non
è un tesoro Vabbè ragazzi uno l'abbiamo
preso l'altro stato D'altra parte del
Lago e direi vamos my boys però è tutto
fortissimo Comunque ormai mi sono
skillato non ho neanche più Madonna che
bello me la ricordavo troppo sta cosa
che potevi andare in giro per il lago
però attenzione Non vorrei ci fossero
cose strane
mostri non credo Ah c'è qualcosa qua
nel lago c'è qualcosa dentro il lago
vediamo
alessandrite va bene la loro insite ce
l'avete Quella vale un sacco e ve lo
dico io
oh Red novel is this fuck in Pistols
equipaggia non è ragazzi Questa è
fortissima Non ho idea di che munizioni
Monti cioè penso quelle rosse No ho
trovato una Red nove Ragazzi
mi ricordo che il residenti vol 4 quello
originale la Red 9 è la più forte cioè è
una delle più forti pistole che c'è
questo me lo ricordavo non so quasi
Sinceramente questo non lo so perché
magari nel remake l'hanno nerfata Non ho
idea ragazzi vediamo dai
Ah le galline forse una che mi dà l'uovo
d'oro
c'è un uovo d'oro che devo prendere per
una questione ragazzi Eccolo No il
marrone eccolo Ce l'ho l'ho trovato
pazzesco che culo ho trovato l'uovo
d'oro quello che mi serviva veramente
Però io stavo scherzando Che culo Beh
non era così difficile Allora la prima
Viola se guardate in giro visto il gioco
ho trovato un sacco di roba in più e
questo che sto residentivole è fatto
benissimo da questo punto di vista vi
guardate in giro trovate la Madonna ok E
così mi so purellato completato 65
missioni che io mi ero ripromesso di non
farle queste secondarie perché sennò ci
mettevo ci avrei messo troppo minchia le
ho fatte senza senza peso mi fate mi
alloggiare ragazzi che scuola facevo
cagare Almeno qua Allora ehm cos'è
questo
Ah vedi che qua c'è un altro enigma
Allora tre serpenti perché anche qua c'è
una testa di me di coso che devo
prendere Allora tre serpenti Ecco la
nuova vista scusate
Ok
Eccoci questo è una sciabola va bene Ah
eccolo è un
po' una m con una cosa che gli passa
dentro al contrario Vabbè quanti cazzo
di simboli sono e tre DNA incrociati Va
bene Allora tre serpenti 3D DNA che
questo una m che ci passa in mezzo al
coso Ma forse la dovevo vedere in
prospettiva lasciavo Eh aspetta ah no ok
cazzate Vabbè perché io parlo Va bene va
bene tutto ok C'è qualche psicologo mi
dica se sono un genio o se o culo grazie
Abbiamo tutto raga eh abbiamo anche
questa testa del Blast Demon sta
parlando di me incredibile Ok ragazzi
allora adesso che abbiamo tutto
teoricamente posso ficcare staffare cioè
le due teste che ho trovato dentro il
coso potrebbe avere la chiave
teoricamente serve servono quelle e
quindi vamos Cioè è uguale l'una con
l'altra non cambia niente basta Sì
di premere con la mano facevi prima però
vabbè Grazie
stemma della chiesa adesso posso andare
a salvare escile teoricamente
ho trovato la chiave della chiesa se non
dirlo troppo alta voce perché
io non ho capito se L'arma che ho io la
Red 9 Utilizza gli stessi proiettili di
questa che avevo prima che a questo
punto la vendo quella vecchia la vendo
mi prendo tutti sti soldi che ho fatto
perché per potenziarla mi Rida
praticamente tutti i soldi che ho cioè
tutti i soldi che ci ho speso e quindi
teoricamente io c'ho fatto un sacco de
Money e mi compro anche il lanciarazzi
ma vediamo dopo perché Per adesso mi sa
che dobbiamo tornare Eccoci qua
Eccoci qua Eccolo lo sapevo signori
Preparatevi perché ci sarà da divertirsi
Gloria alla Playas
ley la Madonna di Dio Ah ho capito di
chi era il teschio dentro il coso di
prima andiamo Come va ragazzi eh
bene La partenza non è perfetta ok
merda merda
E io sparerei anche così va bene
Perfetto proviamo a usare Tipo che ne so
questo
a parte ragazzi che ho tipo sei granate
a frammentazione che non ho mai usato
magari proviamo a usarle
è uno Cioè questo è teoricamente
dovrebbero far male Poi non lo so Ah c'è
qualcosa che gli è spuntato dietro
attenzione
merda gli Ho sputato un coso dietro Oh
eh m'ha preso non so come fa in realtà
non mi ha preso ma vabbè fa niente
Mannaggia il cazzo Ok
a posto colpisci colpisci
Vabbè vabbè
Madonna mi piace L'attacco dei giganti
Oh la collottola fagli fuori con la con
questo morendo cioè non ho troppa vita e
non ho Cure momento perfetto per non
averle Va bene allora vediamo sempre
posso farlo fuori in qualche modo Pam
pure pure
i lupi Ah no Questo qua è quello che
liberato prima al mio cane tesoro sei tu
Sam Ah minchia mi stai aiutando No vabbè
incredibile Quindi se non lo liberavano
mi aiutava Ma no sto male dai attenzione
Porcaccia la [__]
mi ha fatto neanche stavolta mi ha
colpito in realtà se ci fate caso in
qualche modo avere Sam Dammi una mano
per favore Porca [__] Brava colpisci
colpisci bravo
fortissimo Madonna incredibile
È fortissimo non mi schiacciare Non mi
schiaccia
re t'ammazzo Eh mi fanno fuori il cane
lo ammazzo e ve lo giuro
penso che è uscito il coso è caduto Ah
non è caduto
è un [__] è un [__] a posto va
bene vai
lo posso colpire così e io volevo volevo
andare sopra col coltello come prima eh
vabbè morichetti Madonna e quando rutti
Però mettiti la mano davanti alla
finestra a curarmi un pochettino Sì non
ho più Cure però questo potrebbe essere
un problema Però vediamo
e dammi una mano che qua la vedo dura
Porcaccia la [__] stavolta mi ha
preso è l'unica delle tre volte mi ha
colpito effettivamente ok E vai giù
perfetto Vai Vai Sam vieni qua mordi
Mannaggia
Eh cazzo lo dico io Aspetta che se
riesco a prendere le granate forse li
faccio ancora di danno
che le granate non ho capito Secondo me
li fanno niente perché devo colpire coso
sopra
schiva schiva schiva schiva schiva non
hai schivato un cazzo lì non va bene sa
aiuto
sono morto non ho più vita
Ok Bravissimo ancora
Mannaggia Cristian
sono morto Sei carica eh
ce l'ho fatta è morto ce l'ho fatta
l'ultima ero morto andavo vita che Bucio
de culo No ragazzi Ero schiattato non
avevo più niente Sono praticamente
moribondo
ma va bene così stavo per diventare una
Eh l'ho detto anch'io un diamante giallo
ma tutto sto casino m'ha dato un
diamante giallo raggiungiamo la minchia
ma almeno la roba Forse potevo curarmi
Ah aveva sbloccato delle robe
stubbasciardo coltello da cucina Grazie
Sandro Dov'è il cane che in tutto questo
mi ha salvato il culetto Cioè
andiamo Ah comunque ho trovato delle
cure Meno male ragazzi non avevo viste
andava fatto uscire prima ok usiamo Bene
bene che brutta roba qua c'era qua era
pieno di roba
e io che cazzo ne saccio io ho iniziato
la battaglia così non c'è niente forse
me ne sono [__] alla stragrande era
pieno di casino che ho fatto prendere
bene
Oh Samu Dov'è lo sento abbaiare non lo
vedo però grazie prima Allora la chiesa
ragazzi al volo faccio questo il quale
al mercante Io venderei ragazzi venderei
la pistola ve la vendo
Thank you e la Red 9 aumentiamo io
userei questa qua ragazzi la Max Ray
perché secondo me mi dà veramente di
quelle soddisfazioni incredibili Io Max
sto maxando questa raga perché so già
che è la pistola che userò per tutto il
tempo Quindi [__] tutto maxata
però Madonna incredibile c'ho il massimo
già ho la Red 9 che la pistola migliore
al massimo Quindi perfetto ok my boy se
la mia scelta di Giove è stata fatta
Adesso c'ho la Red 9 eh full colpi Tra
l'altro C'erano un miliardo ed è
veramente cazzutissima in culo Salve Oh
merda testiamola subito dov'è È sparito
Ah porco Eh vabbè Ah non è morto mica
pensavo ha detto è già morto ok
ragazze è finito
qua ok Beh beh beh usarla riesco ad
usarla Poi non so effettivamente dovete
installarla sugli zombie normali perché
questo non l'avevo mai fatto fuori cioè
non so quanti brodetti mi ci vogliono
però teoricamente sembra forte ragazzi
sembra una pistola bella incazzata
quindi andiamo avanti è Let's Go In The
Church
Ashley
dov'è
non è grossa eh Comunque mi pare fosse
al piano di sopra perché questa chiesa
c'ha il piano di sopra non chiedermi
amico Non chiedetemi come
un altro enigma dai ragazzi basta
ficcatelo nel culo Cosa devo fare Mi
serve pure uno stemma Devo trovare il
suo stemma ragazzi Vabbè troviamo in
giro e poi torniamo qua piccola chiave
no mi traditrice Non mi servono a niente
ragazzi non ho preso la mitragliatrice
non la sto usando
a me perché le mitragliatrici a me nei
videogiochi Ragazzi mi sembrano sempre
mi stanno di spreco di colpi sempre mi è
sembrata sta mi mi ha sempre dato sta
sensazione di spreco di colpire che ne
sparo un miliardo e un quinto vado dove
voglio che che vada quindi mi dà
fastidio allora A sto punto me ne fotto
Comunque ho trovato la manopola
Let's go ah vediamo se riesco a
sbloccare staffare Ah questo va così mi
ci gioco le palle E vabbè questo va così
perfetto E ora il blu
giusto
io riconoscere l'ingegnere che va nei
villaggi della Spagna più inculati da
chi so io se ne va là e dice minchia
facciamo un sistema di mosaici che
girano per sbloccare quella porticina lì
Ma che cazzo è che fa ste cose Chi è Chi
è Chi è che è andato il Resident Evil 2
nel distretto di polizia a mettere le
cose nascoste nell'estate Chi minchia
Non urlare che siamo in chiesa comunque
Bella la chiesa al piano di sopra qua ci
sta una porta permesso ragazzi Vi
presento
la persona più inutile di questo
videogioco
ci siamo trovati
sono qui per ordine del presidente
[Musica]
cioè l'unica persona che ha dialogato
con lei finora e lei se ne va Cioè è
pericolo
mi devi dare retta che succede
Oh merda
[Musica]
andiamo
o
Grazie
ma non necessito non Necesito merci cioè
gratis
ci leviamo dai [__]
è stato bello conoscerla comunque ha
capito terminato minchia Io volevo
andare avanti così Volevo vedere che
succedeva e anche episodio di oggi è
giunto al termine ragazzi Mamma mia che
gioco della Madonna l'ho già detto un
sacco di volte ma continuano a dirlo
probabilmente vi sia piaciuto
della descrizione iscrivetevi al canale
e noi ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo
episodio di Resident Evil Beh ragazzi